i believe that ronnie knows who he's
voting for
i find it hard to believe that there are
still undecideds out there no i don't i
don't believe that
he's not undecided this is the most
polarized election
in the history of america and he doesn't
know who
if you don't want to believe what i'm
saying fine don't believe it i don't
give a [ __ ]
you know what's so funny you know what's
so funny please tell us
you know or just keep saying you know
what's so funny
yeah you're such a [ __ ] expert on
everything this guy
did you say he was moving to vegas yeah
and huh
yeah an idiot moves to vegas what idiot
i'm not talking about shut this
[ __ ] off because i'm gonna go
right through this [ __ ] computer
right now
[ __ ] him this stupid [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ]
who the [ __ ] he thinks he is what's
wrong with movement of [ __ ] vegas
you stupid piece of [ __ ] you care about
vegas
do you listen to this guy's mouth yeah
what is your [ __ ] problem with moving
to vegas
what's your problem with that it's not a
place where you live it's a place where
you go and gamble you stupid ass
what are you a stupid [ __ ] i don't even
go to the strip when i'm there
listen let me
yeah i'm stupid because i'm retiring i'm
going to relax
unlike you who drives around and thinks
he's so
[ __ ] cool in his [ __ ] cars with
his [ __ ] watches that his father gave
him everything
you're the best member your [ __ ]
father gave you
everything he gave you
guys guys guys no
you got your father's money and that's
how now you walk around like you're
right now walk around like you're missed
a [ __ ] big shot with your [ __ ] fur
coat and everything else
who the hell walks around with a [ __ ]
fur coat
me by the way yeah you because you're a
[ __ ] stupid [ __ ]
i do believe deep down inside ronnie
kind of knows who he's going to vote for
that's my
belief there are there are people you
believe there are people who say
that a guy with a ton of toy cars
shouldn't vote
but i don't say that you know i'm
looking i'm looking at ronnie howard
howard
please howard i'm looking in ronnie's
room and i
and i see the toy cars all lined up
behind him and i say
you know what look yeah
i think what ronnie is saying is that
fur coats
are bad and stupid but toy police cars
are cool
and that's fine they're not hurting
anybody he's not honest
i'm not honest okay i'm not honest okay
if that's what you're saying
that's your opinion that's your [ __ ]
power just saying
said i don't give a [ __ ] he could say
whatever he wants he can say i [ __ ]
voted for the [ __ ] black crows
i don't give a [ __ ] the black crows
listen do you really thank you
thank you for the call thank you i hung
up on him good all right
and i'm hanging up all right you go hang
up on us
you're turning down you're turning beat
red